straight away you need to and this is
what I'm gonna advocate for because if
you come on a platform and you say oh my
man this this did this to me my boy my
boss did it to me and you tell me and I
said so what did you do about you said
nothing I'm sorry I could just cut I
just can't I just can't take everyone
that says that the truth I'm sorry I
can't do that but can we just I think
that's quickly which really really
should add that some women
are so traumatized thank you by what
they have experienced thank you they
find it difficult have you experienced
essay pearly things or you have you
which is which I mean the definition the
definition for essay is so broad now
what is the definition I don't even know
they change it every year but but
arguably I could yeah I could argue that
I have and did you report every
experience of essay yes every single
experience it doesn't happen to me that
many times can we say you were so brave
then for Having the courage to do it but
some women's it's
and it's arguably because it's like
nowadays you can report someone grabbing
your butt at a bar
but if that's not warranted or that's
not invited but some people don't think
that's like a higher enough it doesn't
matter
that's what I say it's so broad but I'm
saying like like if you're to me okay it
doesn't make sense to me if you can come
on a podcast and talk about something
but you can't talk about it to the
police exactly so I understand that some
people like okay they might they might
not want to talk about it publicly or
they might like if they're afraid then
they wouldn't go to my podcast and they
wouldn't go to the police either but so
like again but I still think it's
selfish I think I think if you if you
trust me I'm selfish for being a 17 year
old girl who lives in a hostel you don't
know what I've experienced previous to
that for not reporting my boss who's
probably about 40 years old and excuse
me let me land don't interrupt me I'm
just saying yes I'm not asking you I was
asking pearly things right yes I'm
asking you if you think I'm selfish I'm
a child at this point yeah I've been
sexually
all of them things that you know you can
say
um by yeah like by all you can't you
can't tell me nothing how whatever your
opinion is that's your business yeah
because I know my situation yeah and
what I have walked through in the in
that situation right now I'm 33 years
old yeah so it's different now of course
I can sit down I work with I do I work
in the community but at that age yeah
that young age I am a child I can't even
open a bank account on my own yeah and
you're telling me I am selfish
well whatever you can't do you can do a
lot easier
you're trying to make jokes and you're
trying to interject
diverse
okay okay have you gone through okay
okay no no no no okay you asked me the
question first and then you want it this
rant I did I wanna run you know okay
do I think that's selfish yes yeah I
think because then other girls have to
deal with it
like I just think if if something
happened to me that was so traumatizing
like I wouldn't want other girls to go
through that you like basically I can't
I can't judge other people you can say
what you want and feel what you want
yeah and have your opinion and that
doesn't mean that much to me because you
don't know what people go through what
your capacity is at 17 I don't know if
you went through your experiences at
that age and if you was living in a
hostel at that age and if you had gone
through what I had gone through at that
age yeah we're different people Jonathan
I'm saying to you yeah are you sure I
know we're different people we're
different people so that's what I'm
saying you might have the capacity you
might have the support you might be
living at home you might have your mum
to rub your back at the police station I
wasn't in that situation so there are
many people that are experiencing things
and I haven't got no judgment for you do
what you can do because why is it up to
the victims to find and licked out you
know as a child to to to to build up a
case against these people when you have
the capacity yes
I encourage I support but find an
organization if you don't think you can
do it on your own if you are unsure get
the support that you need the main thing
is that you have got support to get
through the trauma of Very Yes you get
your bum grabbed at a nightclub but
there's varying different traumas
there's a normalization it's called the
police so listen to this I've just
listened to you just no no sorry can I
talk because I just listen to you I've
listened to scars on me
so what you're doing now we'll let you
speak we've let you tell your story and
let you tell your passion but I'm sorry
but the world doesn't owe any one of us
understanding lots of people are going
through lots of things end of the day
it's very selfish for you to be assorted
by a man or whatever you said and he's
40 years harassed or whatever it is but
it's it's made you feel this strongly
about it it's gone into your life and
it's obviously followed you you have let
this man go into the world and possibly
do it to many other women before this is
like knowing a man is actually like um
for example if someone touched kids and
you knew they did that and you never
judge kids no you wasn't your 17
technically okay so if you're going to
keep doing this then we're not going to
able to get off because basically you
setting me up at 17 you can open a bank
account you can open a bank account at
11 years old what tends to happen is a
lot of people come over here and they're
trying to act like oh when I wasn't I
wasn't an adult 17 you knew right from
wrong end of the day if you had any
family any people around you if you
didn't call you to scenario understand
that but you have the police there you
cannot come into a platform and be this
fluid and but it's articulate and
challenged Paul and say to myself oh you
know what I couldn't go to the police
there's nobody around the police is
there then you say to me okay I got
attacked by the police okay so you don't
have or whatever it is okay cool why am
I gonna go to the police okay okay so
now 15 have assaulted Me Okay cool so
now we can't go to the police right so
you know who do we go to well I'm just
discovering who do we report it to you
I'm just discovering my manager who do
we report you're telling me you can't go
to the police most people can go to the
police but you're saying to me so I
don't have to take this on board do you
have
um to see the scars see what you're
doing is yeah because he said
because the moment I do you don't have
nothing to push back on you just really
what big man talk talk let me hear what
you want to say can I present something
a second one second okay okay let him
finish because the thing is yeah we're
not going to be able to have a
conversation if you keep doing this
because you keep getting triggered why
are you getting so triggered like that's
like that no if this is trauma let's not
talk about it because you're getting
very triggered by it and you don't have
to speak about it if this is causing you
trauma because we can't even have a
conversation in order for me to have a
conversation we're gonna ask you some
questions we're gonna have to diverge
and every time I do you get triggered
interrupt me so I I don't want to do it
if we can't do it Paul there's no point
say what you have to say he said you're
gonna land is that is that what you had
to say is that what you have to say
let's take it take it okay that's what I
thought let me let me present something
to you stefia yes for the rest of us to
just listen to so Steph let say you
could you were looking right now at 17
year old girl who has just experienced
your fly on the wall you see a 17 year
old girl who's just experienced what you
went through
um with the police with that with those
situations
what right now sitting here now what do
you think are the steps that that 17
year old girl should take I'd like to
hear from the rest of the panel I've
heard I've heard from two men okay
she's he's asking you what's the
question yeah I'm asking you directly
my advice and my concern is for her
mental health and that she is supported
so I my priority over speaking to the
police which I think is the best course
of action if she feels able to do so is
to make sure that somebody she trusts
whether it's a member of her family
whether it's a friend whoever is aware
of her situation because if she's
feeling low if you know I mean what
that's my concern you're not my general
concern I don't think the number one
concern would be to stop it from
happening again
because because it happened to her so
now it could happen to 10 girls or it
could happen to one girl I think it's a
point of view situation
yeah from trauma and someone coming from
stoicism so it's two completely
different point of views that don't
interject so I get what you're saying in
the sense that say it with your chest
right
those things happen to you they were
awful I'm very sorry but your statistic
is you're coming at home with maths your
math is off right and she's saying these
things happen to me so obviously there's
going to be a a complete non so can I
just stop it I'll let you go on you know
what it is I've come on this platform
before I have three sisters I have four
nieces like I am very much I've just
been spending the whole day with my
niece you can look at my story playing
with them yeah I have a very good
relationship with my younger sister and
we speak about a lot of things so
if you said you never if you don't have
people around you and you can't go to
the police then I'm all concerned that
there's men around here and doing things
to women because I keep hearing this and
this is not how I was raised so I'm like
what can we do to stop this and whenever
but whenever I try to speak about what
can we do to stop this or what can we do
to at least bring awareness to us it
just goes round and round around a
suggestion of what people can do to stop
this is perhaps okay right something's
awful has happened to you you don't feel
like you can say it right you don't feel
like you have that safe space to say it
so you hold on to it it becomes an
internal trauma and then when someone
mentioned it to you you fly off the
handle that's how most people handle
these situations but what you're saying
is what can I do so when someone flies
off the handle yeah don't come up with
them with maths come at them from I
understand
that you are this reaction comes from a
place of fear and anger you're asking
them to communicate like a woman not a
man no no no in fact I'm asking him to
just communicate with me no you're
asking him to communicate well then
you're putting different versions let me
let me sorry sorry one second again
we've come to the dichotomy as well yeah
one second this I think this is
interesting so go back to machiness and
like you know dominance of men over
paranormalities
you know in a very subtle manner you
can't divert your vocabulary Alex Alex
you're gonna jump in after me but hold
on a second what you're doing is what
see okay so you're doing tone police and
we get this every single week no because
you've literally just done what the girl
did the last week and the girl did the
last week if you go look on my story on
Tick Tock it's going viral every single
time a man speaks I have a woman every
time a man makes a point it's every time
a man makes a point now it's your tone I
was even trying to no no but what I'm
talking about Alex let me just say and
you can just literally come after me
pull you go but the reason I want to
speak about this because men we speak
direct we are not women okay so we have
a different vocal tone we have a
different bass on it right when a man
articulates himself or men are direct
what women tend to do we go around the
houses we've just spent a lot of time
going around to get to the bottom of
something I completely understand what
you're saying but when you speak about
men's tone we are not women and you
don't want us to be women that's the
point that I was making I thought that
you over you didn't understand what I
was trying to say Powell was saying that
she was mating trying to make you speak
as if he was a female yeah you can't do
okay that's part of it yeah the reason
of this whole topic which is men
harassment within the workplace and what
we were saying about how men can come
across towards women when we are
innocent do you think Alex will just
take this for me you can't die what's
the word like you can't what's you can't
like be a woman adapt that's what I'm
looking for being sensitive to her no
it's adapting like adaptation you can't
adapt you're not even choosing to be on
a level to be like you know let me try
and work out know what I need to be a
female because physically you can't be
yeah we understand that but there's a
part of your brain that can click
no no because basically what you want me
to do is you want me to basically tiptoe
around this whole thing no because
basically all I've done is simply ask
her a question I've listened to what
you've said I've asked you why didn't
you report it you told me you couldn't
go to the police you told me you got
scars you've told me all the different
things here cool but if there's my
concern is is that when this happens
women don't and it's men that's walking
around and it's continuing to happen to
so when I say what can we do yeah
because if the girl in your situation
now and she hasn't got Brothers she
hasn't got family she's in a hostel as
well yeah what does she do she can't go
to the police
what you can do someone just gave you an
example is that as a man what you could
do for a woman or a young girl in that
situation someone else is giving you an
example of what you can do I was asked
what I'd advise other young people in
this situation to do so if you you asked
in a question feel free to listen to
some options you don't have to take them
on as I think these are valid examples
on TV that states exactly this way it's
like a guys I'm in the park of his
friends whether or not a woman's Class A
guy turns around such rubbernecking oh
yeah right rubbernecking is like a
saying of like when a guy you know
breaks his neck to like put Jesse's at a
woman or just throw things out you just
throws it throw things up verbally like
messages like maybe I'm saying oh he cat
calls yeah there's so many different um
terminologies but Robin is a terminology
obviously what's wait what is the cat
calling have to do with them now calling
is more a vocalization whereas yeah
rubber necking is the Turning of the
neck yeah but it was both it's like when
they're like damn yes yeah that's what
I'm trying to say yeah the way it is
that bad I'm trying to land not
necessarily that's a bad or a good thing
but the point I'm trying to make is the
advert was stating sexual harassment and
they were saying that basically within
that situation let me land quickly
um the guy turned around and his friend
basically was like to him like don't do
that AI he stepped in and allowed him to
like understand that maybe that woman
might feel it's inappropriate maybe to
his mind he's just like oh what's your
number you look nice what them jeans are
tight or whatever do you feel like essay
to me personally I've got a bit of a
stronger exterior and interior so those
things don't really phase me depending
on how I'm approached so for myself no
but for another woman that's a bit more
fragile than me do you think that's
confusing for a man it can be yeah
like even with the workplace like the
number one before as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible